Speaker 1: Let's start today with Brian
from Gainesville, Florida, in Gainesville,
Florida. Gainesville, Georgia. Brian
from Gainesville, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hey, David. Yeah, doing well and
yes, that's that's Georgia, not Florida. Thank
you. Yes. So I was I was the caller who called in
about the triage question about a month or so ago.
OK, so I'm really disturbed by the amount of
anti VAX propaganda coming, particularly from
nurses. And I'm just curious, what do you what do
you think we should do as a society about that?
Speaker 1: I mean, I've said before the
best protection against disinformation
is an educated, critically thinking population.
I don't think that going after nurses and again,
I agree with you, there's a disturbingly high
amount of disinformation coming from nurses.
Anecdotally, I still think nurses are not nearly
the primary vectors of disinformation. But but
it is particularly concerning because nurses
are someone that many people might say, well,
it's a medical professional. I should be I
should be able to trust what they say. We
actually have an email I'm going to show a little
bit later on in today's show, a couple of emails
actually about this. I think that we really
have to just educate people and teach people
how to evaluate whether something they're being
told makes sense. And unfortunately, you can't
do this in six months in the middle of a pandemic.
It starts much earlier. So it's a real conundrum.
Speaker 3: I completely agree.
Speaker 1: Yeah, do you have any ideas?
Speaker 3: I to be honest, no, I don't I don't
have any specific ideas that that come to mind,
you know, I hesitate to say that, you know, if
you're a nurse and you say something that is that,
you know, that that that is false, I hesitate to
say that you should just lose your job. That seems
you know, that seems like it might be might be
kind of draconian, depending on the the context.
Speaker 1: I mean, here is one thing I think is
important to keep in mind. Very often people will
say the best way to fight bad ideas is with good
ideas. But there's actually a problem with that
because fear, uncertainty, doubt, catastrophic
predictions are much more salacious and
appeal to people much more. Write negative
headlines do better than positive headlines.
You're actually at a structural disadvantage
just by countering wrong information about
the vaccine with correct information, because
there's something about the wrong information.
This idea of this is what they don't want
you to know, that makes it stickier. And
so we actually need something more than just good
information. I don't know what that something is.
Speaker 3: And there's so much there's so
much misinformation out there that it just
takes so long to to go through everything point by
point. It's kind of like how and arguments people
Gish Gallop a of kind of how I see that very
much. Oh, it's too much of it out there.
Speaker 1: Well, we'll keep fighting.
Speaker 3: Mm hmm. I agree, I should.
Speaker 1: All right, thank you so much
for the call. Thank you, David. All right,